this video was made possible by dashlane
browse the internet faster and easier by
signing up for free at dashing calm /
Wendover on November 3rd 2020 hundreds
of millions of Americans will all make
their way to their local polling
stations to cast their votes deciding
who will be the next president of the
United States of America that day will
be the accumulation of a multi-year
multi-billion dollar election process
but before that all truly ends the votes
need to be counted and the winner has to
be declared as soon as the first polls
close at 6 p.m. Eastern Time there
begins a massive overnight exercise to
count hundreds of millions of votes and
typically declare who will next lead the
country by the early hours of the
following morning while the true effort
doesn't start until the early evening of
voting day the first results come in the
early morning of election day before
most polls have even opened a few small
towns on the East Coast most famously
Dixville notch New Hampshire all compete
to be the first precinct in the u.s. to
report results New Hampshire state law
allows polling places in the state to
close early as long as all registered
voters have cast their ballots given
that the town only has a dozen or so
registered voters this process is
typically finished in minutes or seconds
in front of a cluster of cameras from
nearly every major news organization the
votes are read out and tallied the
process of counting a dozen or so paper
ballots in a small town is not tough but
a few hours later the rest of the
country's polling places will open each
of which eventually has to accurately
count up to thousands of votes what
makes the US election so difficult to
conduct right is that there are over one
hundred and seventy eight thousand
individual voting precincts each of
which can and does do things in a
slightly different way some use paper
ballots that have to be read and
interpreted manually some use paper
ballots that are scanned by a machine
some use electronic voting machines and
some even allow for absentee voting over
the Internet
the selection of a voting method is a
difficult balancing act handwritten
paper ballots are simple and cheap which
means that a polling station can process
loads of voters at once but they're much
more difficult to count electronic
voting machines are expensive and
complicated meaning they're often in
short supply leading to longer lines but
counting and reporting the votes have
almost instantaneously also a major
concern in the selection of voting
method is security the most secure
ballot is no doubt a handwritten paper
one as submitting a fraudulent vote
involves physically acquiring and
submitting a ballot something that can't
be easily done at a large scale arguably
the least secure method is electronic
voting machines as anything electronic
can be hacked
almost every voting machine out there
has been hacked in some way or another
in controlled experiments at hacker
conventions such as DEFCON in the real
world it's impossible to know for sure
how often voting security has been
compromised but we do know that these
machines can be hacked which is why
still today much of the u.s. votes the
same way it did hundreds of years ago on
paper ballots first to close their
polling places will be parts of Indiana
and Kentucky at 6 p.m. Eastern the
second that happens everything shifts
into counting mode both states use a mix
of optical scan and direct record
electronic voting machines for example
the majority of Kentucky's machines are
heart intra Civic II scans these are
those optical scan electronic machines
where a voter physically fills out a
paper ballot shading in bubbles for
their preferred candidates then feeds
the sheet into a machine which scans the
responses and then records and tallies
the votes in Indiana however the
majority of their machines are micro
vote Infinity's which are examples of
direct record electronic machines these
are fully electronic machines where the
voter selects their candidates of choice
on the screen before pressing a button
to cast their votes when 6:00 p.m. rolls
around though the machines as voting
modes will be turned off they will print
out a physical paper back up displaying
the tally of votes for each candidate
and the poll workers will remove a sort
of memory device that stores the totals
every step of this process has to be
witnessed by multiple people usually of
different political parties these papers
and memory devices are all then packed
up in sealed envelopes and gathered
together from there the votes need to
make it to a central vote counting
location usually they're driven there by
the county's police to assure there is
no interference that works in most
places but not all for example anyone
who's been in Los Angeles in the early
evening when their polls close knows
that would take hours to get a vehicle
from Gorman on the northern end of Los
Angeles County to Norwalk where votes
are tallied therefore the count
uses helicopters to fly voting records
to norwalk from across the county and
therefore ends up spending many millions
of dollars on each Election Day traffic
is less of a concern in Indiana and
Kentucky though and so not long after
6:00 p.m. Eastern votes will start
arriving at their essential counting
locations where all the memory devices
will be plugged in to a tabulating
computer that will record at the results
they'll also add in the results from
early and absentee voting as well give
me electronic nature of this count when
votes have physically arrived at the
site the process doesn't take long but
throughout it all it will be observed by
a bipartisan group of poll workers and
officials of course the way the world
hears about the results of the election
is not via the government itself but
rather through the media almost always
the media tells the public who will win
the election before all the votes have
come in and they make this call based
off two key pieces of information the
first is election day polling there are
two competing systems of polling the
first is the Associated Press's vote
cast system a relatively new method
where voters are polled at home via the
internet and phone in the days leading
up to Election Day and the second is the
national election pool system used by
ABC CBS CNN and NBC this system uses the
more traditional exit poll method where
individuals leaving polling stations are
asked who they voted for in an attempt
to gather a representative sample both
of these systems give media
organizations an idea of how voters are
leaning on election day and help them
know where the results are likely to
swing the second major data point used
to project election results are the
results themselves a small sampling of
results from a County should be roughly
representative of the county's results
overall The Associated Press stations
about 4000 of its reporters in vote
counting centers all across the country
and as soon as these counties report
results the reporters call them in to
the ApS office in Spokane Washington
they're one of hundreds of data entry
personnel will answer the phone and put
the information into the AP system these
data which may at the time of entry be
unofficial are used by news
organizations all around the world
throughout the night results will come
in precinct by precinct and the AP will
call the results precinct by precinct
the last polls close at 1:00 a.m.
Eastern time in alas
however more than likely the country
will already know who has won the
election by that time the APS DC Bureau
is in charge of calling the race
they'll one-by-one declare each state
one for one candidate or the other
some states they'll know from the second
polls close which way they'll go for
example in 2016 the highly democratic
states of Massachusetts New Jersey
Delaware and Maryland along with the
District of Columbia were all called for
Clinton by the AP the very minute polls
closed in those places at 8 p.m. Eastern
the AP just knew off of historical
voting trends and exit polling that they
would certainly go blue
meanwhile battleground states with a
fairly even mix of Democrats and
Republicans tend to be trickier to call
and require a good proportion of actual
results to come in
for example Minnesota's results in 2016
weren't called until 11 o 9:00 a.m.
Eastern and Alaska is not until 11:58
a.m. Eastern on the day after the
election far before the last state is
called though the combination of
electoral votes designated to the called
States will exceed the required majority
270 and at that time the AP will send
out what they call a flash these are the
very highest tier of AP alerts reserved
for as they describe it events they
expect to be one of the very top stories
of the year the AP averages less than
two flashes a year and such an alert has
been used for events like the killing of
Osama bin Laden the resignation of Pope
Benedict and the death of Nelson Mandela
it is not always the AP who is first to
call the race but more often than not
they are the first major news
organization to declare a winner
historically this tends to happen
between 9:00 and 11:00 p.m. Eastern
but sometimes much later and sometimes
much earlier from their tradition kicks
in and the loser calls the winner the
winner throws a party and the next day
the sitting president calls the
president-elect the true official
results might not come in for days or
weeks as States work to tally every vote
not reliant on probability the moment
that happens though the clocks reset and
the US and world again begins the
four-year process leading up to the
election of the next American president
what evaluating products I might use
like everyone I'm always looking for a
vote of confidence and for dashlane
there are 11 million users there were
top rating on the App Store and their
endorsement by the New York Times Wall
Street Journal Forbes and more tells me
that it's a product worth using what
everyone sees in dashlane myself
included is that it's a simple way to
make browsing the internet faster safer
and more efficient
- leans securely stores things like
passwords addresses frequent flyer
numbers passport numbers and plenty more
and then auto fills them when they're
needed so that everything happens faster
it syncs all this information across
devices no matter if it's Mac PC iOS or
Android so is always there when you need
it you can make your Internet experience
faster for free for 31 days by going to
- link column / Wendover after that by
using the code Wendover you'll get 10%
off upgrading to - Lane premium